I listen to your talk on the summit. You mentioned the generational damage because we were bored with bad genes.
Are those things that can be repaired with healthy lifestyle and future offspring will be okay.
Plus ourselves, or can it never be reversed?
Well, there are practitioners out there that say that you can change your genes by taking these supplements or doing these different things.
But you can't, I just totally disagree with that.
I'm open to it. Show me the proof. It's really easy to retest the person's genes.
And you know, if you change that person's genetic picture, then, then great.
There's never ever been the proof that that happens.
Once you have a genetic gene defect, you are going to pass that on to your progeny.
And there's, and that's the way it is.
Now, if we were able to go back in time through some sort of magical apparatus and test our ancestors, I will guarantee that they did not have same number of defects that we have.
So what causes our genetic defects is we inherit genetic defects from our parents.
So if they have a double allele defect, you're going to inherit at least a single allele defect.
Secondly, you acquire defects because of toxins.
So you're exposed to benzines, you're exposed to pesticides, you're exposed to different chemicals that can affect those, you know, defects in, you know, cause a defect.
And you're a set of people are 50 or punal pathways.
And now, if you have children after that point in time that you caused that defect, you couldn't, and you could, they could inherit that defect from you.